Donald Trump's attorney, Evan Corcoran,
arrived at a Washington, D.C. courthouse.
You can see him there
to testify
to a grand jury
without the protection
of attorney client privilege.
Corcoran must also hand over
documents and notes
related to his legal work
with the former president.
This is all about the Mar
a Lago classified documents investigation
and his Cayman plants
live outside the courthouse
in Washington, D.C..
Evan Corcoran is inside.
Caitlin, so what's happening
Indeed.
Evan Corcoran is inside the courthouse,
and we do believe he's back
with the grand jury
at this point, a little bit after nine.
His attorney is here as well.
So it is quite clear
that he isn't complying
with this court order,
that he provide answers
he did not want to give
and that his client, Donald Trump,
did not want him to give
to the grand jury
about their communications
as the federal government
was trying
to get to trying to get back
classified records at Mar a Lago.
We learned last night from my colleague
Sara Murray and a source
she was speaking with that
what they want to ask him about
is that response after May of last year
where the federal government
sent a subpoena
demanding all classified
records be returned to them.
And there
clearly were conversations
between Corcoran and Donald Trump then
including in June.
That is what we know
they want to ask him about
and that he is going to have to respond
to today.
Inside the grand jury,
he did just go in a few minutes ago.
And typically
these types of appearances
can last for hours.
So we are going to be waiting.
It is entirely confidential
what happens inside that grand jury room
So we won't be able to see it
like we do other court hearings.
But this is really a critical day
for the special counsel's
investigation
and also a really unusual day to have
a lawyer
for Donald Trump
being forced
to come back to court and testify again.
John, it is incredibly unusual.
Caitlin, Paul,
as we know, you're watching it closely.
Let us know,
you know,
when the white smoke
comes out of the building,
when people emerge,
when there is information
about what went on in there.
Appreciate it.
I will joined now
by former federal prosecutor and CNN
legal analyst Jennifer Rogers.
Jennifer, as we've been saying,
this is highly unusual
for a defense attorney
to have to testify like this.
The prosecution
the special counsel,
obviously, this is a big get for them.
They got him there.
What do they now
need to try to get from him?
So Caitlin said the first thing,
which is the circumstances
around the certification
it was submitted
in response to the subpoena saying
we have diligently searched
for all documents,
that we have no more documents
with classified markings.
That document was drafted
by Evan Corcoran.
But he didn't sign it.
Christina Bobb, another Trump
lawyer, signed it.
So the question is,
where did they get that information?
Did they get that information from Trump?
Why did Christine a bad sign
of everything around that certification?
The second really important thing is
that there was a conversation
between Corcoran
and Trump
on the day
that the Trump Organization received
a subpoena
for surveillance footage from Mar a Lago.
People were seen bringing boxes in
and out of the storage room.
Why did they do that?
What was that conversation?
I mean, you can imagine
what would have happened.
We got this subpoena,
what's going on at Mar
a Lago with the boxes, Mr.
Trump and that conversation.
So that's another topic they're going to.
So even perhaps at this
very moment is going through something
that very few attorneys have ever gone.
There you have it.
Certainly sitting
before a grand jury
having to testify about your client.
What are the
just the challenges for him,
the professional challenges for him?
Yeah, well, this is something
you obviously would never want to do
when you talk to your client
in that context.
It's supposed to be confidential.
You don't really have to worry
about talking around things right.
You can be fully candid with one
another under that protection.
That protection has now gone away.
So that's not great for him.
Listen, he doesn't have a choice here.
He could take the Fifth,
but I don't think he will.
That's not a great
look for him professionally
because it means you're not testifying
because it might incriminate yourself,
which in theory,
a lawyer should be in the business
of incriminating himself or anything,
you might say. Right. Right.
And it's probably not true. Right.
I mean,
the government at least doesn't think
that he actually was involved
in this conspiracy.
They think that Trump lied to him.
So they either
would go challenge that invocation
or probably just give him immunity.
So they're going to get at it anyway.
So he's got to answer
just about everything.
Yeah.
I mean, everything that he didn't answer
before they had him in before.
So now they're just going back
to the questions that he said.
Attorney client
privilege and vacation and asking this
all right.
While that is going on
in Washington, here in New York today.
I joke nothing's happening
with Alvin Bragg,
the Manhattan district attorney's
investigation into Donald Trump
regarding the Stormy Daniels hush money
payments, things connected to that.
The grand jury is not meeting today.
We think they are going to meet again
on Monday.
Donald Trump overnight
put out this statement
on his social media platform
where he
cited the possibility
of death and destruction.
If Alvin Bragg presses charges
you're dangled that theory out there.
I don't want to ask you an attorney
about the propriety of a human
being saying that he also continues
to say things that are that are racist.
If you are in the office of Alvin Bragg,
if you are a prosecutor,
how do you react to something like that?
Well, it's really hard to be under,
first of all, this kind of scrutiny.
Of course,
it is around this whole case,
but those kind of threats
are really disturbing for anyone.
I mean, listen, Alvin is a professional.
I promise you.
I know him well.
He will not be daunted
by that sort of shenanigans
by the former president.
But it is troubling.
I mean, obviously,
they'll have additional security
and those sorts of things.
But to be under
that kind of attack is really disturbing.
But in the end,
you know, it won't matter to him.
No, of course.
Move ahead with their case.
Jennifer Rogers, great to have you here.
Thank you very much.